I think the European Union is superbly
positioned to become a major player in
the 21st century and it has done quite
well the common currency the
centralization necessary centralization
coordination through European law
European courts have done a great deal
of good to the continent that was
divided so long I think Europe faces two
fundamental challenges that are very
hard to overcome the first challenge is
the demographic challenge a gray
incontinent Europe is graying much
faster than the United States is and so
Europe has to deal with that problem
that means that not only there are more
people who want to retire and and get a
state pension that means that every year
you have about two million people that
are missing in the workforce because
they retire and you need to replenish
them two million that means two million
immigrants from somewhere there isn't a
country close to Europe large enough to
supply two million immigrants a year let
alone the the question of cohesion of
integrating these people into the
European culture so Europe has and faces
a huge challenge much more so than the
United States the added challenge of
course is and that's the beauty of the
United States the beauty of the United
States is that it it pushes itself to
the brink but it never falls off once
it's at the brink even extremely close
that then comes back and it retains its
unique spirit of entrepreneurship and
innovativeness Europe needs to begin to
harness that and begin to believe in its
own ability to be entrepreneurial
creative and innovative and to believe
in itself so far it hasn't done that
it's still always eyeing towards the
United States I think a little bit more
self-confidence would do it
good